orioles and the red sox tonight on a
thursday evening from camden yards as
tonight begins the first of a four-game
sex the right-hander asher wojciechowski
red sox first and third with two out
here and now here's mitch moreland
runner goes swinging a deep drive right
field santander back on the track
jumping up and santander riddles this
one in
against the 21 foot wall in right field
jump was timed perfectly by tony he
takes a hit away and two men left on
base for the red sox
runner's head job first and second
[Applause]
little looper here and that's going
gonna drop down for a base hit
here comes vasquez
he is in to score the throws cut and the
red sox take a one-nothing lead peraza
with some good hitting
red sox already with four hits in the
ball game against wachowski
got jammed on that one a ground ball to
alberto go to first base as the run
comes in to score couldn't handle it
would have been a double play ball they
had a shot at it two nothing boston you
see his hand yeah it came off his his
heel to his hand almost lost complete
control of it did get the out but the
run scored
bring up xander bogarts
swinging a high fly ball down the line
dripping out of here felinka back to the
wall leaping up can't get it it's gone
sander bogart strikes number five put
the red sox in front three to nothing
what an easy swing that was you know
it's just a very easy lazy fly ball that
leaves the ballpark i'm gonna tell you
what adds up to this home run and some
of those base hits the other way where
he's staying on the baseball and all of
a sudden he gets a pitch that he can
pull and he can pull whenever he wants
to
just like a changeup
that just rolled right into the barrel
of his back
just an easy little pass a little pass
you know didn't crush it just enough to
get out of here boy i'd hate to pitch
here the seventh inning has been the
getchy inning for the orioles this year
they've outscored the opposition 20 to
four in the seventh can they find some
late magic tonight's former ucla bruin
valencia
with a fly ball last to right center
bradley on the case bradley at the wall
it is gone
pat valencia
punches one the other way
and the orioles score in the seventh
again
as valencia breaks the shutout
well that's one way to get that party
started seventh inning you mentioned a
little seventh inning magic
one two coming
swing and a miss he put him away
vazquez will have to throw on that's a
strikeout so out number two pitch is
swung on and grounded to the right side
moreland has it flips underhand to
avaldi steps on the first base bag in
time to get velasquez strong effort by
native aldi that's for sure red sox have
a 3-1 lead as we go to the eighth inning
seven innings for nate five hits one run
six strikeouts yeah nicely done
they're on it first and third for xander
bogarts
and a shot for a base hit
radugo in to score red sox lead it four
to one yeah o2 slider he left it and he
made him pay moreland tonight is one for
three with a single and walk
high fly ball center field that's deep
mullen's back turning it's gone
mitch marlon strikes again and cleans
off the bases a three-run shot here in
the ninth inning yeah the red spurt i
mean red sox first three run home run of
the year goes to mitch
moreland and he puts this game away is
what he did
well you talk about how important
location is when you saw the catcher
severino give the fastball sign he
wanted it upstairs he wanted it over the
lettuce he didn't get it there he got it
right down the chute
here's the payoff pitch
from valdez see ya and struck him out to
end the ball game red sacks win it
7-1 their second two-game winning streak
of the season nathan of aldi gets the
win and he was outstanding now two and
two
mitch moreland with the key blow
the ninth inning three run homer and the
sox come out on top
seven to one